clearing the path for TTIP the european
commissioner for trade cecilia Malstrom
attempted on wednesday to reassure any
piece their concern is the mechanism for
solving disputes between investors and
states that would allow investors to
bring an action against a government in
a private court of arbitration we have
legal assistance and in particular if we
are speaking about the United States and
European Union then we have quite good
functioning legal system so why we don't
trust them so that is not explained in
behavior this improved system would move
away from individual ad hoc cases to
become much more like traditional courts
and it sets out clearly that our goal is
a permanent international the action
plan for a digital single market was
unveiled it is one of the priorities of
the young convention it's about helping
businesses and consumers trade across
borders making it as easy to trade
online as it has been offline but it's
also about things like data protection
and cyber security and safety online the
digital single market could contribute
an extra four hundred and fifteen
billion euros per year to Europe's
economy
what is the potential of the Lisbon
Treaty to improve the functioning of the
European Union this question was posed
on Wednesday started with the Treaty of
Rome all European treaties require
Europe to have its own resources to
honor that spirit would mean creating a
European tax while allowing national
taxes to be reduced for even greater
consistency the period of the multi
annual budget could be brought down from
seven to five years to match the
duration of Parliament's legislative
term and finally a small reminder this
Saturday the 9th of May is Europe day
the EU institutions will open their
doors to citizens